Bob how much time did you spend on the
father-son aspect of the story versus
the actual you know what would happen in
the first act second third Oh during the
writing process they cooking this up I
really one of my favorite films is the
Bicycle Thief and I really wanted to
capture that type of father's sudden
interaction so it all started with that
and as I was plotting out the film I
wanted to make sure that we were
tracking their relationship all the way
through the film and then I built the
scenes around that and in terms of their
relationship what did you want to happen
what was crucial in in the first act
second and third I just wanted this very
gradual subtle connection to start in
the beginning they when he touches to
say it's almost you know there's not a
big hug or anything and we don't really
see that at the end necessarily but I
just wanted to make this incremental
progress through the film almost so you
don't even notice it's happening so that
by the third act they're basically
together trying to solve this problem
that they have right it sounds like
father and son stories are also very
close to your heart as well yeah so with
Nebraska I know you did press and I
think you said at that time that you did
not really want to direct but you knew
it was crucial for the film's at your
budget level how do you feel about that
now having directed the confirmation uh
yeah I believe that's almost necessary
at this point in filmmaking and I
encourage all writers screenwriters to
take a try at directing i'm glad i did
and i hope to do some more it's just it
if you give your script to somebody else
no matter how good they are you don't
know what's being done to get your film
made and I'm not always going to be as
lucky to have Alexander Payne directing
wanting to direct one of my scripts so I
think it's better to give it a shot and
see if you like it you live in
Washington I believe in it
okay would you be able to live in Los
Angeles and still come up with the same
ideas and dedication versus living
someplace a little more secluded maybe
but I tell you when the I after I option
Nebraska I spent some time in Los
Angeles and I went around and did all
the meetings and I did studio
assignments and I didn't have a new
original thought of my own when I went
home and relaxed and stopped doing the
studio assignments and got back in
Washington State and just started thing
all of a sudden the ideas game so I
think maybe I'm just tensor down in LA
or whatever it is and and the idea is
flow at home but it certainly helped me
any advice for a writer that lives in a
more thriving metropolis where they need
that alone time and advice on how to
find it and and were to sort of hone in
because it does get drown out here and
well you know you just have to find your
space that you like to write in I mean
I'm I'm shocked a lot of writers like to
write in starbucks they like to be out
there with the noise and the feeling of
people and that's good for them if you
need to be alone like I right in the
dead of night out in the woods that's
what I need to get through it but
everyone's got their own process
excellent wow thank you all right I'm so
exciting oh thank ya oh I wish I could
find that in LA yeah